[Applaudissements]
si jamais tu laisses la colère te
contrôler un jour cette colère te
détruira
on la fera partir la planète devient un
surpeuplée et se meurt un petit feu
est-ce que cela est juste que nous
devions partager avec les pauvres
laissez les s'entretuer cela facilite
notre travail pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
du côté de praiogo l'argent ne peut pas
acheter tout le monde madame ce ne sont
qu'une immense bande de cafards qui
doivent être exterminés et si je refuse
cette offre
qui est vraiment cette fille
qu'est-ce que je viens de faire et il y
a quelque chose qu'on doit te dire
Jaga pour me c'est le nom de notre
cercle
notre travail est de traquer de protéger
les descendants de la déesse assis
mais qu'est-ce que tout cela à avoir
avec moi
tu es la prochaine incarnation de la
déesse assis
[Musique]
vous souvenez vous de l'histoire des
cinq commandants de la déesse du feu il
est l'esprit démoniaque
plein de haine plein de ma liste
[Musique]